i'm now joined by yulia ivachenko who
moved out of mario paul and she joins me
now thank you very much indeed for your
time here on sky news and julia you've
had a journey haven't you just tell us
about that and also how you managed to
do it with two children
hello uh two weeks ago my fam died like
it is so much
mario pal now it's a real hell
and
we have to survive in any ways for
example we need to cook
food on fire in front of our houses
because uh we have no gas no water no
electricity no mobile connection no
internet or central heating
we drink water which is melting of snow
also the water from batteries of the
central heating
we eat
food cooked on fire only once a day
and it was difficult to cook food
because the bombs are falling all the
time and the planes are flying
and we know exactly and my children knew
exactly that if the plane is flying two
or three bombs are falling and exploding
and if they fall not in our house we
knew exactly they will fall in another
one uh we sleep in cellas and all
citizens of mariupal have to sleep have
to sleep and sell us uh on carpets
and
once when we went outside we saw that
all around us were burning and um we
have to
make a decision what to do first or stay
at home and
and
survive like this yes or to go further
and save our life
very likely our car was not damaged and
we got onto our car and
all my family with all my my family and
we uh luckily we uh survived we got all
this hell to the nearest village the
road was very dangerous and very
difficult uh the planes were flying and
they were
throwing bombs into us and all fragments
of bombs uh
were flying and getting on the roads and
uh sometimes into people so it was very
very dangerous very uh scared but
luckily and the god save saved us
and we got into the nearest village uh
and
now we know that our houses are burned
completely and my parents houses are
also burnt completely we have no
plans what to do now we live in hostel
in the middle of ukraine in the town
nipper and um
and we don't know exactly what to do
further
yes and julia what you've just described
is just devastating and i'm just so
sorry to hear that you've had to go
through all of that with your family and
with your two children as well
and what's also even more sad is that
you've talked about a city that you you
will not be able to return to because as
you say your house has been brought down
attacked
yes about 90 percent of houses of mario
paul are burnt and
it's not possible to
restore them again
and what is the plan for you now are you
hoping to stay where you are in dinipro
or are you hoping to get out of ukraine
um
i don't know exactly we have no exact
plans because uh men in ukraine are not
allowed to go
abroad
so we must stay
if we want to stay together with my
family we have to stay in ukraine so now
we think that we will stay in ukraine as
much as it possible because the
situation can change very fast and we
don't know exactly where what what to be
tomorrow for example
so
in nipper it's also not very safe
because uh the rockets are also flying
sometimes
but it's not so dangerous like in mario
pal mario paul it's a real hell
yes i was just going to ask you about
where you are now denipro what's
happening of course you know you're
you're hearing um rockets there um is
this very frequent are you hearing it on
a daily basis what is it like there now
in nepal it's quite
it's
quite
quiet not very dangerous but
the
signals or
we are we can hear from time to time and
we have to go
to
uh safe places uh in uh sellers or
something like that but it's not
um the bomb it's not bombing it's not
like in marijuana
and um julia i just have to very quickly
ask you you know how are the children
doing how are you doing how are you
how are you feeling at the moment
uh at the moment they are okay but they
are afraid of any noises
uh they
know exactly their
sound of plane
and uh now they can change this uh sound
with the sound of wind for example or
any other noises so
they react in any noises for example
cars
or some
usual explode explosions that can happen
in our usual life so they
can scare any noise
but
still they okay and uh maybe if we live
in mario pal some more time uh
their
sickness
their
situation can change in very bad uh
bad condition i think and i know that
they're very young as well and i know
they're seven and twelve so it's it's
just too much for
any child to go through and for anyone
regardless of your age and um julia i
appreciate you taking the time to speak
to us sending you all the best here take
care of yourself
thank you very much thank you